MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Juggling is hard.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
this is even harder
than setting up
logging and monitoring
for my cloud infrastructure.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Actually,
if you use Stackdriver,
it's a piece of cake.
STEPHANIE WONG: What's that?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Stackdriver is a tool
that lets you monitor and get
insight into your applications.
STEPHANIE WONG: Sounds useful.
How do we get started?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Let me
jump right into a demo.
OK.
To start things off, we're going
to take an instance that I've
just set up here and
go ahead and install
Apache and PHP into it as
kind of a basic example.
So I'll go ahead
and SSH into this.
And this is just a
brand new small instance
I've set up that I haven't
done anything with yet.
But we want to make
sure that we actually
have something to monitor.
Of course, using
Stackdriver, you kind of
want to monitor and log
different events that
are going to come out of,
in this case, the default
Linux properties.
But you can easily configure
that to add additional logging.
We're just going to step
through the basics here.
So I'll go ahead and
install Apache and PHP.
Go ahead and let these update.
And once those are done,
we'll make sure everything
looks good, and then we'll
install the actual Stackdriver
agents.
So nothing special here.
Let these run through.
OK, we'll skip that 30 seconds.
And now that it's
all set up, we'll
go ahead and make
sure everything
looks good by bringing
up this in a new tab.
And we can see, there
we go, we have Apache2
successfully installed.
So now what we're
going to do is actually
install the agent itself.
We're going to go ahead and
look at a quick script that
basically just grabs
the different agents,
the monitoring agent
and the logging agent,
and then installs them.
So we'll go ahead and run those.
And while that's
happening, we'll
go ahead and take a look at
the Stackdriver interface.
That will probably
take about a minute.
So we know that Apache works.
And in the Google
Cloud console, we
can take a look for Stackdriver.
Now, if this is your first
time setting up Stackdriver
or clicking on this monitoring
link which takes you
to the Stackdriver
interface, you
may have to go through
a small set up process.
Basically, you're
just going to choose
what GCP project you're using
and some other small set
of steps.
That can take another
couple of minutes as well.
But once you have
that set up, you
can easily just come
to this interface
and switch projects like you
might already be familiar with.
So once we kind of have
those logs installed,
we should be able to go here to
resources, click on instances,
and we should see that the
instance is set up right here.
You can see another instance
that I had set up earlier,
but lamp instance is the one
we want to take a look at.
So I'll click on that.
And you can see just by kind
of running that quick command
line, we have the
agent installed,
and it's already monitoring some
of the more standard metrics
that you might see
on an instance,
including CPU and memory
usage, network throughput,
these kind of things.
So this is a great way
to kind of just quickly
get that set up.
One of the other great things
you can do in Stackdriver
is actually set up a dashboard.
So if you go to Dashboards
and hit Create Dashboard,
you can start to add charts.
Charts are basically
these metrics
that you're going to be able
to select from a list here.
And kind of choosing
your instance,
get a better understanding of
creating a custom monitoring
dashboard for the metrics
that you actually care about.
One of the other important
aspects of Stackdriver
is going to be alerting.
So by setting up
an alerting policy,
we can easily take a
metric on an instance
and tell Stackdriver to notify
us when something happens.
So if we go ahead and
add an example condition,
such as our instance here--
oh, we already have an instance.
We'll pick our lamp
instance, and we
can go ahead and choose
something like, if the CPU load
average is above 80%--
that might be something
that we're concerned about,
because maybe that
means our web server is
serving too much traffic
or some process is locked.
We'll go ahead and choose that.
And then we'll add
the notification.
So here we can add
an email, we can
add an SMS, a couple of
different integration options
here.
There are tons of
things we can do.
And then in
documentation, we can just
add some additional
texts in case
we want to set up some more
advanced monitoring or just
in case we want to
know what kind of flag
or what group this
was set to, we
can use that for custom text.
Name the policy,
and then save it.
And that way, we'll get notified
in case anything happens.
Now, the next part we'll look
at is the actual logging.
So if we come here
and click on logging,
we can see the default
logging interface which
is also using Stackdriver.
On this dropdown here, we
can choose what instance
we want to look at.
In our case, we're going
to look at lamp instance.
And in the subsequent
filter, we're
going to go ahead
and choose syslog.
Once we've set
that to the filter,
we can see all the
different things
that have been sent to syslog,
just so that we can measure
whatever applications
might be using or whatever
any other loggings--
well, anything that gets
sent to syslog, really.
Just like that, you can set up
logging, monitoring, and more.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
Now I'll have a real grip on
my application in the cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
If only it was that easy
to learn how to juggle.
STEPHANIE WONG: Don't forget to
comment, like, and subscribe.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And if you
want to get in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.